i'm going to jump in and just say that
i've seen the first four episodes i
can't express to you how much i loved
them they're they're so they're so good
it's what i've been waiting for and i
think that it's because there's no jedis
lightsabers skywalkers or or desert
planets it's other stuff that's
happening in the star wars universe can
you sort of talk about that aspect of
the show yeah man i mean i think that's
what attracted this i mean well me too
who knew about the star wars universe
but um the writing was so different to
what i ever expected and
he's created a whole new section of the
universe you know it's expanding an
intricate way
and all these characters are so fully
developed and they're all
really messy and real
and gritty and
relatable
and they're all intersecting and
interweaving in in
an amazing way
and um
i i certainly hadn't ever seen anything
like that in star wars before yeah same
and i you know i didn't really have
anything to compare it to because i
hadn't seen any i have never been a star
was
not that i wasn't a fan i just it never
really was my thing and so when i was
in talks about being in it i
tony let me read the first three
episodes to get a flavor of what it was
because i was like i don't know i'm a
theater actress i'm not sure this is
what i want to walk into like what if
it's all just like in space with green
screens and i don't know how i'll feel
about that and then i read these three
episodes and i was like hold on
this is not
this is not what i expected it to be
this is like a dance and there's so many
characters and i you know because i
wasn't in those first three episodes the
fact that i was so into it was such a
good sign because i wasn't reading it
from a well what's my character's arc
through this i was just like oh my god
how has he done this and then he told me
what dedra would come in and do and i
thought
any party you want me to dance at tony i
will i will be there yeah and the fact
that it's like a socio-political
thriller as well as like a business
comedy almost as well as like nice drama
kitchen kitchen sink and then like a
love story and like and it's star wars
there's not a lot known about your
characters and i hate asking the generic
question i hate it but um i really do
but because i'm going to be running this
way before it comes out what are you
allowed to say about your characters so
i'm i'm playing dead ramiro and she
works for the isb and she is an
incredibly ambitious
uh woman in this man's world and she
she comes she's sort of seeking to get
to
a place of power within this regime so
that she can feel like in control and
um
and yeah everywhere she looks she sees
people not taking things seriously it's
like you know in the trailer andor says
they're so
fat and something
they couldn't imagine that we would get
full of themselves
she sees that too she's looking around
and going
they're fat and full of themselves
lazy
and so she's like razor sharp and in
order to get to where she wants to go
she's prepared to go to any lengths to
do that because as far as she's
concerned she's saving the empire
you know she's gonna go into the empire
and tell them this thing is happening
and unless you do something about it
we're all in danger um so yeah it's kind
of dangerous to be
in a fascist regime when you're somebody
who wants ultimate power because you do
some pretty horrendous things to um
yeah but she's super sweet and nice and
like you know
she dates she takes she bakes yeah she
crafts yeah you know yeah
and that's really where where dedra and
cyril kind of yeah they're crafting
mainly tailoring yeah they both like
like their their uniforms have to be
tailored to look really perfect and when
i heard that that was like what cyril i
asked for that in my fitting and the
designer was like that's you know that's
what cyril does like he needs everything
tailored and i was like oh we are gonna
be great together
what what can you actually say on uh
about your character so cyril karn is
working for the corporate security
sector at the outer reaches of of the
galaxy and um where there's not much um
imperial presence at all and he's
desperate for imperial presence he is
like
as he is with cassie and andor he is a
dog with a bone to get into the empire's
good books and he would be a perfect um
little ss officer for them
um
but he really has a strong moral core
um which is just misguided you know he's
he's drunk the wrong kool-aid
and all the freedom and the messiness
and the
the kind of
um complexity that cassian represents
he's just fills him with such anger
that he can't exist within that within
his own world
and so he is desperate to
transcend his own station and um
at any cost which
makes him a kind of perfect um match for
dedra when they wind up
crossing paths yeah i have to ask you
guys is it fun playing a character
doing and saying things that you
completely disagree with
yeah yeah and who says i disagree with
it
because i can understand why you know
they both do what they do which is the
amazing thing about tony's writing it's
like it's so three-dimensional that
you're like oh yeah i get why
he would do that or she would yeah i
mean i have a scene where i'm doing
something
so [ __ ] up and i'm doing i have this
scene where i'm doing just it's just
horrific and i thought i finished and
one of the guys that was in the scene he
was like man that was
that was really something and i was like
i know right so good and i could see him
going wow she really enjoyed doing that
i said yeah
i mean where else do you get to do this
stuff you know and playing the sort of
baddie is always
so much better i do a lot of like it's
so much more fun
yeah to not have to have compassion or
empathy like my life is spent constantly
crying and you know feeling so much for
everybody that to play a part where i
don't have to feel anything it's quite a
nice change
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say again thank you so much for
your work in this it's fantastic can't
wait to see the rest thank you so much
thank you
you